freunde ich bin hier in meiner
heimatstadt köln letztens an einem
restaurant vorbei gekommen dass nicht
hellhörig werden lassen hat und zwar das
restaurant ahoi von steffen henssler
kein geringer als der steffen henssler
hat in köln ein restaurant auf gemacht
und ich dachte mir direkt da muss man
hingehen dann dachte ich mir ich mache
ja auch mit videos und dann dachte ich
mir ich mache dieses video oder
schlechte wahl ich wusste überhaupt
nichts davon dann habe ich als
allererstes mal die website aufgerufen
wir sehen also ahoi heißt ella relativ
einleuchtend ich glaube steffen henssler
kommt aus hamburg oder zumindest so aus
dem hamburger raum und ich stelle mir
erst mal vor das ist da wahrscheinlich
wir sehen bei den bildern so schieben
wir sehen steffen henssler und ich
glaube sein bruder und wenn wir mal auf
unsere filialen gehen hamburg
heimathafen haben wir also hamburger
travemünde scharbeutz otterndorf und
dann halt köln in diesem gefüge ist köln
auf jeden fall der exot und
dementsprechend bin ich auch gespannt
wie funktioniert dieses restaurants und
steffen henssler was anscheinend im
fokus hat in köln wir haben uns ins auto
gesetzt in 15 minuten aus der innenstadt
heraus gefahren und dann waren wir auch
schon da okay sind angekommen leute und
ich muss erstmal sagen gute gesellschaft
hier hier ist einfach ein autohaus von
bentley und lamborghini direkt nebendran
da war es mir direkt was abgeht ich habe
angst dass ich jetzt gleich sehr sehr
viel geld ausgeben werde aber wir gehen
rein mit versteckter kamera micro ist
auch versteckt das kommt guck mal da
sitzen sie drin das ist so halb drinnen
halb draußen können also bisschen
gehoben preislich auf jeden fall so
haben wir so viele preise sind sämtliche
zehn stimmen von denen die hier draußen
steht gibt es noch mehr da steht auch
extra auszug aus der karte ist auch
stefan metzger sieht schon gut aus aber
hier nur so kann hier wird so heuser
konzeptionell durch fiktion nordsee
mäßig war durch den haupteingang gehen
wir schauen uns das alles mal etwas
finde ich auch wild meter nach paris
gerade bei würde ich so ein kanal
gruppen
das ist wenn dir nichts neu habe gesagt
mal schauen ob wir uns weiter darauf
setzen hier kommt man auch chili hier
drin
die motorwelt beziehungsweise lang so
ist also gast das wilde hier stehen halt
richtig kranke bin ich schon cool wenn
das hier direkt angrenzt oder ja schon
brauche
einfach mega kicker aber nicht so
knallig gesondert jetzt auch gut oder
direkt alles durch gezeigt man ja keine
halben sachen nicht moderne gast drucken
sowie ich sehe erster blick gibt es auch
nur ein gericht unter dem 10 und es ist
der klassische diesen salat wo ich mein
es am ende des tages ist ein krasser
auch berühmte persönlichkeiten und es
ist alles schön und gut aber das essen
muss derzeit legitimieren eigentlich
etwas haben wir den salat jung-soo cho
beim fischen chip na ja wir haben
zwischendurch kleine rezeptvorschlag ist
eigentlich was für die story oder das
ist das für dich soll ja da kannst du
direkt meine story können auch in der
mitte aber richtig durchgespielt und
fritten zufrieden henzlers teil zu
machen wird sie mit blackjack und gewürz
und safe verkauft er das lage technisch
stetig gedacht ist nicht so krass aber
man hat fast so ein bisschen so ein
schild weist
sehr sehr schlimm sind chips ich sag
ehrlich alles zwischen schönsten chips
18 uhr nina burger auch sehr welt tun
fürs
thema zu tun versteckt markt
ist immer da eigentlich der und das wird
geil jetzt sauer waren bin ich auch
nicht so schaaf weiter zum liege
besucher dafür dass sie 100 auch schon
was loswerden nachmittag
fischen chips henzlers teil für das
klingt so als wäre das so das gericht
das ist auch irgendwie golden markiert
hier in der karte ja mit den fremden
hensler style pepperoni creme und
remoulade hier ist ich will mich gar
nicht so sehr steigern aber anscheinend
wird der ganze spaß in so weißen fahne
ketchup mayo kosten auf 60 sind standard
aber heutzutage ja außer ist es dann
diese billige in der tüte ernst editions
ernst schwer in ketchup mayo berechnet
werden ja ja ja es ist ein grundrecht
die gassen menschenrechte
ich fahre gerne an und zweite ich gern
den thuner bürger und zudem pommes die
triple cremig einmal gern fischen chip
sensation chips henzler sei wir haben
angriffen rolf steffen henssler wird
also es ist schon sehr prominent ja aber
ich meine der hat sich ja den namen
aufgebaut und jetzt kommt es aber darauf
an ob dieser gute name auch vom essen
abgebildet wird denn wir sind ja auch
quasi kollegen nennt habt ja auch ein
youtube channel von taipeh auf jeden
fall sehr sehr nah ist das einzige was
ist ein bisschen zäh aber ich sag dir
ehrlich ich könnte mir vorstellen dass
es gar nicht so ohne weiteres möglich
ist neben bentley mit dem restaurant
aufzumachen man fühlt sich wohl hier
aber für mich zeigt es ist außerhalb das
muss man dazu sagen also schon für
außerhalb wieder echt teuer aber für
händler wieder okay also das irgendwie
seien außerhalb eigentlich zu teuer dann
aber henzler und produktauswahl machen
kann mir ja irgendwie ein bisschen weg
ja ich bin auch weiter bild und
dankeschön dankeschön popcorn hat es
jetzt ja noch mal nicht mit branding
costa wenig aber es müssen
es ist die idee des brotes vom essen
aber neu interpretiert und einfach ein
bisschen poppiger natürlich
super danke sehr
lecker aus sätze lang
ja meint er auch gefangene sogar elf
zähler story muss her oder save aber das
ist ja schon mal ein wichtiger punkt sei
selbst in
der presse war
das gegeben ist weißt du was hat
wirklich sehr frage ist dieser bürger
klar preis ist hoheit nicht aber ehrlich
portionsgröße ist wirklich stabil guck
mal hier wie meter die soße so und so
geraten kein zweck gläschen
fans das teilten die wirklichkeit nicht
so sammelt eigenen geschmack mit
irgendwas vergleich
weiter das ist mir nicht ganz in der
kritik das ist ultra
bekommen dass auch in diesen kasten
somit sind die vergleich über im sopran
schrieb hat man
dabei sind wahnsinnig langen will jetzt
fühlt sich geil wir sind ernsthaft
machen uns macht spaß zu essen mit chips
sondern das ist ja mal weiter essen
waren das angebot ist eingetroffen
jetzt bin ich gespannt weil leute schaut
euch das an das richtig kruste ran also
hab ich erstmal gut ist aber ist ja
jetzt ist er jetzt jetzt jetzt zuerst
da ist richtig was drauf muss ich auch
ehrlich sagen 98
große pommes oder extra
vokabel drauf wochen ist groß deshalb
hast du in diesen krassen teriyaki
nimani geschmack natürlich sei das schon
geschehen ist so nicht erwartet oder er
liegt mir ist auch hat erst beim
reinbeißen noch mal bewusst geworden was
ich erwarten darf einer der bekanntesten
in deutschland hast du nicht der
bekannteste kaufst du auch wenn
letztlich gekocht hat konzipiert so sein
name steht da drauf und wir würden
nichts zum ausgeben was ja nicht
absegnet werden komplett schrank ich
frag mich freue wenn ich das essen warum
gibt es nicht überall zum geschenk
machen oder
jetzt mal ehrlich das schätzt sind ohne
80 gramm und das typische 150 gramm mehr
also auf jeden fall die bürger nehmen
diese kruste schafft nicht mit am
meisten korrektes mal an harte groß dass
man schmeckt die auf
mich würde es nicht wundern wenn ihr
triple freiheit sind christen die
popkomm ist sowieso ein mantel wir haben
erst mal durch
und falls praxis strich aber ansonsten
was ich sagen kann mit der burger
vielmehr weil da einfach so viel mehr
abgeht bewährte bitte nur das für sich
stehende also tischen chips in seiner
kategorie und wie es jetzt hier schmeckt
dafür ist es super wir jetzt jeden
geschmack einmal getestet weil andere
probiert werden jetzt auch jacob er sagt
geworden sind lassen das ganze schon mal
ein bisschen sich setzen und
deutlich dass ich selten lassen auf
meinem teller es geht nicht alles es ist
so eine große portion eigentlich wollte
ich noch das härteste aber ich sage euch
es geht einfach nicht nur eric auffiel
dass es krank wir sehen uns gleich im
büro für die bewertung das restaurant
ahoi von steffen henssler war mir bis
zur eröffnung in köln nicht bekannt umso
gespannter war ich auf das was man von
einem sohn namens starken lokal erwarten
darf in der karte offenbarten sich
leicht gehobene preise das ambiente
schafft erstaunlicherweise ein nordisch
maritimen flair in unmittelbarer nähe zu
einem gewerbegebiet
doch jetzt zum essen der thunfisch
burger war ausgezeichnet der backfisch
einwandfrei und die fritten henzlers
teil waren eine willkommene abwechslung
zu standard sowohl von ihrer textur also
auch von den verwendeten gewürze für die
kombination aus preislage und essen gebe
ich vier von fünf punkten das war also
meine bewertung leute ich fand es sehr
sehr nice in besuch und wir sehen uns im
nächsten video wieder lassen leichter
ist ein abo da wir wollen die 1 million
schaffen bis dahin macht's gut